hello everyone welcome to pi data global
2021 i'm florian and i'll be the host
for this session
and i'm delighted to have with me
reshma and needing to talk about
deploying a mobile app on tensorflow
lessons learned
reshma
is a statistician and data scientist
based in new york she's a founder of
data umbrella a community for
underrepresented persons in data science
she's also a triage team member of
scikit-learn and an organizer for the
new york chapter of pi ladies
nidin is a senior machine learning
engineer at walmart labs
with this i'll hand over to both of you
for the presentation looking forward to
it
okay um welcome to our presentation
deploying a deep learning model on web
and mobile using tensorflow javascript
and react native and this is um
overview of our journey through that uh
my co-author on this project is nathan
pathaniel and you can find nathan um on
twitter and github at npata01
um and i am uh you can find me at rachma
s on twitter github and linkedin
so i'm gonna go over um the outline of
our presentation i'm gonna go over the
data set that we used um and then i'm
just going to show a brief a brief short
demo of the web and mobile app
uh i'm going to go over some computer
vision concepts and um
also
we're going to be going deploying on web
and mobile
so the data set that we used is data
from the train spotting of
foodspotting.com
website and it's 101 of the top food
categories it's a thousand images per
class
and this data set is also available on
kaggle and tensorflow datasets
so this is just a brief gif of our web
app and there's options to either upload
an image or take a url and
it gives a prediction
of the top five
possible
with predicted probability
our source code is available on github
that register s slash deploying web app
and the heroku app
link is over here
and this is just a gif of our um
demo app
uh web demo mobile app and um there's an
option to do a camera or a um upload an
image or take a picture and it gives the
top three predictions
now i'm just going to go over a couple
of computer vision concepts so we used a
convolution neural network we use deep
learning because we're working with an
image data set and since 2012
convolution neural networks have become
the standard after the
well-known famous image net competition
and cnns are composed of convolutional
neural networks with max pooling
operations
so i'm going to show here a baseline
performance of architectures and this is
based on these are benchmark numbers and
they're based on the imagenet data set
they're also based on web not mobile
and we looked at a we worked with a few
family of architectures um there's vgg
19 resnet 50 and mobile net v2 and we
can see that you know vgg 19 the size of
the model file is quite big 549
and mobilenet v2 is used for mobile web
deployment and we can see that it is
much smaller at 14 megabytes you can see
that despite which family of
architectures we use the accuracy is
similar
and the prep this represents the
parameters in the model which are you
know correlated with the size and we can
see as for mobile net v2 the number of
parameters of the model is three and a
half million which is much much lower
than 144 million
this right here gives the inference time
on cpu
and we can see also that as we use
mobilenet
it is much
this much faster on mobilenetv2 and for
the cpu it uses a pretty powerful
machine 92 core
um and the inference time on gpu we can
see it's also
faster from open that v2
versus resonant 50 vg19 and just to note
that this is based on a pretty powerful
gpu it's a tesla a100
so we use model optimization and the
reason is that you know the 14 the 14
megabytes is much smaller than other but
it is a bit too large for a mobile
deployment and so what we do is we
optimize the model and we optimize auto
so we reduce the size and reducing the
size of the model has all these
downstream effects which are which are
favorable
it takes less storage space it takes
it's faster to transfer the model
it has a smaller download size so it
uses less memory and it takes advantage
of the hardware on our devices
quantization
is it's a conversion technique where we
work we work with the model size and
it reduces the model size um without um
much of a loss in model accuracy and
those we could you know we have
comparable accuracy we can save time
um
and we can save memory and so this these
numbers right here are also benchmark
numbers and they are based on the
imagenet data set um and it's on a pixel
2 phone and we can see that mobilenet v2
for the inference time is about 90
milliseconds and after it's been
quantized it um goes down to 54
milliseconds the model size is
about half and we can see that the
change in accuracy is not very different
okay and with that i'm going to uh hand
this over to within
cool so uh thanks reshma so um you know
now we have our optimized model right so
now we want to actually make our model
uh available for our users so you know
the most obvious way to do that is to
deploy the model as a service
right so in pyton land you know we have
some very great uh web frameworks like
we have flask we have fast api we have
django
but one of the problems with you know
these
web servers is that they're not really
optimized for model serving so
one popular model serving especially for
tensorflow is tensorflow serving from
google
so
um it's optimized for model serving
because you know it can sell multiple
models
uh it
it supports like micro batching requests
so you know especially if you are using
an accelerator like a gpu you know if
you have like 50 requests coming per
like per second uh you can have all
these requests you know automatically
concatenated and fed to a gpu so you
know kind of better utilizing the
hardware
and you know especially in production
you know you want to get like these
model metrics captured so tensorflow
serving has all these options
so especially for production this might
be
one
uh one way of deploying but in our case
you know this is just kind of like a
hobby project of ours and we also wanted
to have like a interactive front end
so
we decided to just go with fast api
so you know that's deploying on the
server but you know there's actually
been recently a new deployment option
too
and that's deploying on the browser with
tensorflow.js
so tensorflow.js is a javascript machine
learning library from google that runs
completely on the browser
so you know you can take an existing
keras or tensorflow model you can port
it over to
tensorflow.js and you can even actually
train new models
on the browser itself
it supports multiple platforms slash
backend so you can run inference just on
the cpu
uh it can also utilize webgl and web gpu
so that means it will actually take
advantage of the gpu that might exist on
your machine in the browser
uh it can it also supports like node.js
so you can actually run javascript
server side and it also supports react
native
and you know the beauty of going this
route is you know once the model assets
are downloaded
uh locally by the browser uh you know
infants runs completely locally you know
there's no server or whatnot
so you know tensorflow.js seems exciting
you know let's look into what it takes
into converting
um the model to use this
and some considerations to think about
so one thing is you know we went from a
14 megabyte model to a seven megabyte
model artifact
but this binary file size is still a
little bit large it's not really mobile
it's not really browser friendly right
so
uh what you normally would want to do on
the browser is to have maybe small files
maybe less than one megabyte or so so
that you know the browser can download
all these files in parallel and you know
also like you don't hit any
browser cache size limit
and uh so here you know we set a really
large value for the
weight chart size of 50 megabytes
but we just used this because you know
later since we're going to be deploying
it as a mobile app we just wanted to
have one shot so that's why we just put
a very large value but it's not really
recommended if you're just planning to
deploy on the browser
so the next thing to think about is you
know the model that we trained
uh and we exported you know from keras
you know it's an h5 file um it's is that
the model can be later reused for
training right but if you're only going
to be using it for inference you know
there's a lot of layers inside the model
that are not really optimized for that
so especially if you're just going using
for inference what you can do is you
know you can drop some of these layers
so you can fuse some of these layers so
the conversion script that we're going
to use is basically going to create this
graph analyze it and then
you know drop or combine these layers
the other thing that we can do with the
script you know it is apply quantization
as the ratio i mentioned so you know
normally you might go from 32 bit
precision to 16 bit position and you can
even go down to uh indeed which is uh if
you if the accuracy works
for your use case and the script allows
you to quantize you know just some
layers by layer types or you know at a
certain level in deep in the model
so let's see how all these things play
together so
um here's uh
the script tensorflow.js converter which
is uh which you can install from pip and
uh here you see all the things that we
mentioned you know we take
uh we have a keras h5 model we output it
to a graph model
uh we asked it to export it to basically
one shot we apply
float 16 quantization and then we export
it
so you know great we have our tensorflow
js artifact uh you know now we can load
it in the browser
we can build a nice ui with our favorite
javascript library of choice
but you know like maybe there may be a
scenario where you know the
browser might not be the ideal thing
right it might be very difficult for a
user to always be in front of a computer
so maybe you want to make it more
accessible to your users so mobile might
seem like a good option
so uh
you know globally people have been
spending more time on their mobile
devices and i can definitely say that
it's true for me too
and um you know so you do want to
especially if this is an application
that you think might be useful for your
users you should try to make sure that
it's more accessible to your users so
it might be useful to consider mobile
inference and there are other benefits
for mobile infants too right so
if the inference is running on your
phone then you don't need any internet
connection right
and if you don't need internet
connection that means you're also not
sending you know users messages or users
images to a server right so you're
protecting their privacy and also
because there's not all this bandwidth
for sending the payload to a server
the latency can actually be lower right
um
so
i hope you can see like you know there
possibly a lot of benefits from uh
mobile inference so let's see you know
what are the benefits of action or how
do we actually get there
so
um
you know if you are targeting only
iphone users you know there is core ml
from apple right so
uh
and you have to use uh you have to uh
you have like you have to write a swift
app right because that's what ios and
apps are written in
uh if you want to target both android
and ios you know google has tensorflow
lite
um which you can target both platforms
but you need to write separate code
bases right there's a swift app for ios
and then there's a java app for android
and but last year there's been really a
new option uh the react native adapter
for tensorflow.js so we thought that
tensorflow.js can be used on a browser
it could be used on a server for node.js
and now it can also be used with react
native right so react native is a
cross-platform
mobile development framework so you just
write in javascript
and there are bindings for native ios
and android views so
you can take advantage of basically just
one code base
so another reason why you might consider
using javascript is uh you know
according to stack overflow you know
javascript is a
widely used language so there are a lot
of resources that you know you can use
so for our use case we decided to go
with tensorflow.js react native because
um
we were more comfortable with javascript
and if you look at the chart here you
know
the swift user base is pretty low right
it's only used for mainly ios
developments
so
yeah we decided to go with tensorflow.js
and
you know like what is the code to
actually use this so as since we're
using uh react native and tensorflow.js
this code that you see here is the same
code that's used in the browser and also
in the mobile app
so in the first three lines you know
we're just basically loading the model
we're basically loading the model
artifact
uh and
line three you're just basically loading
a mapping from your
uh model output to like a friendlier
name and then in line five you just
basically load the model the graph model
in line six is you just basically feed a
tensor in
so this looks pretty easy right it's
javascript it looks pretty familiar the
apis look clean
so maybe other than the ease of use of
maybe react native you know is any other
benefits of maybe going this route
so you know react native and i would say
technically expo you know this is a lot
of tooling that's built
for this environment right so
uh so not only do you only need to
develop once you know like but if you
want help or
to deal with the whole process of
deploying to the app store and whatnot
expo can actually
do all that management of managing your
secrets building the binaries
and
also because of the way how expo and
react native is where it's basically
javascript code
depending on the types of updates you
make to your application you can
actually um
update your source code and you know
export the
export your app updates to expo and you
can actually have your users instantly
getting updates your app outside of the
usual android and ios release process of
you know publishing
uh binary
cool so you know now let's get to the
demo stage here so let's just hit this
uh
the web app demo and
later show the mobile demo also so let
me just reload this page
so as reason i showed earlier you know
you can select one of the urls so upload
your own url and on the left hand side
we will be doing inference where
we're calling uh the server that's on
heroku uh like the flash sorry the fast
api backend and on the right hand side
you will see inference actually running
with tensorflow.js
so you know let's see which one is
faster right
so you know for this image you know we
basically get about the same classes
with about the same confidence
we see the inference time on the server
is 300 milliseconds about 300
milliseconds but the whole total time
was about 853 milliseconds
on the browser side we see that it's
about 179 milliseconds and it's not
really much out of time because most of
the time the image is already loaded in
the browser and so the inference just
happens
let me just run predict again because
you know probably you know the model
needed to be loaded on the server the
first time maybe some there may need to
be some setup action that happen on the
browser
so now we see that the inference time is
42 milliseconds but there's still a
little little bit of unstability again
on the server side let me just run it
again
yeah we see like the clients uh the
inference on the browsers about
stabilizing like let's say 40 or 50
milliseconds
i would say 40 to 50 milliseconds is
wonderful for the browser
uh so why did we see like a large uh
time in the beginning in the beginning
because you know tensorflow.js
is kind of uh binding to like webgl to
kind of used gpu
and uh so like the first time it needs
to initialize um like the mapping to the
webgl shader programs so
that's why it took some time but after
the first compilation of that
you can just reuse those assets so
that's why we see such a
um fast time here
uh yeah one thing to mention on the
server side here you know this is the
model without any optimizations so
you know an optimized model can run in a
pretty
pretty fast manner in the browser
so
the next thing is i want to show you
um
it also on mobile so let me take my
phone here so here i am casting my
android pixel 4a phone let me open the
expo app
so
so this is the mobile version of our app
and
let's choose an image
so let me just choose this kcd image
and
we see the inference here so
this is react native running
tensorflow.js so the total time was
about 340 milliseconds
um but the prediction time was about 60
milliseconds
so kind of let's look into this a little
bit
uh you know uh this inference time a
little bit more so let me just move to
saving
and uh let's go to the slides so
so on the desktop browser we saw we're
able to get 40 milliseconds
um i didn't show the mobile browser but
if you run the instance
you get about 175 milliseconds
and as we saw in react native
the inference time was about like 50
milliseconds
um
so
you know i think these are acceptable
numbers um
but maybe if you want to have you know
better for your application if you maybe
need better numbers
let's see what options we have
so if you really do want better numbers
you might want to consider tensorflow
lite
so in the first column we have just cpu
based inference uh using 16-bit
quantization
so we see over the years if you just
look at google's flagship kind of phone
you see cpu inference has definitely
gotten better over the years
and obviously if you can quantize to ins
you can see that we're getting all the
way from 80 to 22 milliseconds
which is great
but if you look at the right hand side
we we have something called
neural network
api so
both apple and
google has you know like custom chips
that they have on their phones
so if you use tensorflow lite you can
use uh it has adapters to
to use some of these uh accelerated apis
and if you look at this you know like
in the beginning the first versions was
not really good it was even slower than
the cpu but if you look at like the
results for
google pixel six their latest model
they're getting all the way down to two
milliseconds and if you can quantize to
ins that's 1.5 milliseconds
i would say these numbers are really
amazing right like if you note if you
remember before when we looked at the
uh tesla a100 numbers that reshma showed
we were getting like about four
milliseconds on our server-side
gpu but here you know we have a
we have that same mobile-friendly model
but you know
quantizing it and you know taking
advantage of the hardware and we're
getting really great numbers
so you know kind of just closing out
some things and some takeaways you know
like
uh
they are you know it's not always enough
like to go after like maybe like the
fast and the newest and latest models so
they're not really optimized for mobile
and if that's some a use case that you
want to consider you know do consider
these
uh if mobile efficient models like
mobilenet
uh they're actually a newer version
there's actually a new version of mobile
network a mobile net we use v2 but
there's a v3 and this entered a family
of architectures called efficient at
light
which
which give about the same accuracy a
little bit better but
the efficiency is even much better
and you know like running inference on
the
uh
running inference on the browser on the
phone is doable right and you know you
can use tensorflow.js and a react native
adapter to get pretty good performance i
would say
but if you really really want the best
thing you should consider using
uh tensorflow lite or core ml to use
like the gpu accelerators and advanced
chips
so you know if you found this stuff kind
of useful like richmond and i have a
course that we created with manic that
kind of walks you through some of these
deployment methods and some of these
information
you can also read about the stuff that
we presented uh at this medium blog and
you can again find the links to our code
um yeah in the to read posts here
and um that's about it um uh if guys
have any questions i definitely would
love to help answer them
thank you so much great great talk there
um
so far i haven't seen any questions but
everybody in the audience feel free to
post your questions now i would have one
i remember i
deployed kind of a computer vision model
on the kind of
the the little
[Music]
raspberry pi type of but the jets nano
as well
so i had like some challenges so i'm
just curious what was the kind of
biggest challenge that you were facing
when you when you did the deployment on
the kind of mobile browser what was the
nitty gritty thing that you didn't
expect at the beginning that ate up some
time
sure i i can take that so um
i would definitely say you know like the
python tensorflow library is very well
maintained
and tensorflow.js it's a little bit
newer it's also kind of well maintained
but like
the react native adapter it's like it
seemed to be honest like a little bit
spun off project a little bit and maybe
because it's just newer
um so
you know like dealing with compatibility
with the python model with tensorflow.js
and then tensorflow js react native
adapter like
um
like we had to get the versions kind of
right because they definitely didn't
make
it easy um
so like when we played with it you know
we couldn't directly use things from
tensorflow hub because
the conversion from python to
tensorflow.js it didn't support like the
hub layers
um so i would say that was one of the
biggest thing like just dealing with the
versions
um
again for our case you know luckily we
were just using on a browser in the
phone which has a little bit more
compute than
um
uh than like the edge devices but it was
kind of uh i guess enlightening and a
little bit sad to see that um the big
difference right if you really wanted to
get the best performance you uh should
use like you know tensorflow like you
can get two milliseconds versus
uh like the 20 or 40 milliseconds
great thank you so much yeah yeah
version problems i
can i feel the pain
all right um i don't think we have any
for a question at this point um let me
thank you again for the great talk and i
hope you enjoyed the rest of the
conference thanks everybody in the
audience as well
and yeah have a have a great
conference